[Music]  kanye west is out of the hospital and  spending time with his family the rapper  spent nine days at UCLA Medical Center  for what one source called a mental  breakdown and according to another  source he is home resting with his kids  and quote happy to finally be back home  the source adds it's Saints first  birthday on Monday and he is happy he  can be there for that there were reports  that Kim and Kanye were having marriage  troubles our source says those claims  are simply not true quote they are like  any normal couple where they do have to  work at their marriage and they do as we  previously reported Kim mostly stayed by  Kanye side through his hospitalization  [Music]